today i want to talk to those you guys
that are actually killing it in business
yes you you're doing very well you're
the number one guy in your company in
the industry everyone in the community
knows who you are you're making money
you have the success but you may have
one blind spot that i want to highlight
today and if that blind spot i highlight
you have the choice to say pat totally
disagree but if you say man i have never
thought about it this way before give it
a thumbs up subscribe to the channel let
me get right into it this last week i
held a leadership retreat at breakers
hotel which is in palm beach and i do it
every single year it's a different
meeting that i host
and it's two three days where we start
seven o'clock in the morning and we go
late
uh i think the first time we start at
seven ended at two o'clock in the
morning second night we started at seven
we ended i got home at three o'clock
last night literally i got home three
o'clock this morning is when i got home
driving from palm beach to fort
lauderdale but it's intense from
beginning to the very end right
and there's a moment in this entire
session where
everyone the people that are doing 10
million or more with their business
upwards of 40 million they're all
speaking talking about what they're
doing with their business
and you're l watching the level of
you know how they're studying each other
and level goes up up up up
the second top earner speaks and i watch
them
give a message powerpoint great message
they grab a seat i'm sizing everybody to
see how much they're taking notes how
much they're trying to learn what their
intentions are what areas they want to
improve in
then the last person gets up and speaks
gives a message
then speaks then explains their strategy
how they did it
so detailed
where it's as if
she went 30 minutes it was magical it
made no sense what she did when like
you're watching it was a clinic
here's how we do this here's how we do
this and the formulas were so smooth
and transferable that anybody if they
applied it they would have the kind of
success with the business
and i'm sitting in the back i'm walking
back and forth i'm pacing back and forth
i'm watching everybody everybody
non-stop because i'm looking to see
who's the one that's going to figure out
the next level in business because when
you start making money one of the things
you start doing is everybody starts
telling you how amazing you are and you
stop having those blind spots because
your paranoia is gone your fear is gone
you're worried about going to sleep at
night about how you're gonna pay your
bills are gone everybody tells you
flatters you nonstop waiters waitresses
employees everybody just bows down to
you so no one's really telling the
weaknesses that you got
she's speaking
i watch the number two earner in the
room that's sitting to the right
sitting there no notes
almost a little bit disinterested
like yeah
you know
got it
okay
cool
boom like one of those moments where
it's like when is this thing going to
end
and then i tease them about not taking
notes
and then i come up and i wrote something
on the board i said everything in my
life has levels meaning
relationship friendship to meets all
levels everything about friendships in
my life is levels meaning
if you and i just met i'm very friendly
we just met we're strangers it's lowest
level right next level is i come to the
restaurant you're a waiter we see each
other seven times now you're an
acquaintance okay
next one i know about you you know about
me maybe we got a relationship next one
we break bread together we have dinner
because if you have break bread together
you have dinner there's some kind of
relationship
next one we travel together let's just
say level five relation we travel
together we get to know each other next
one next one next one next one and then
there is that only one person at the top
that knows everything about you one
person not 10 not 20 not 40 it's one the
level below that's five right i can go
hang out with friends and travel and
have a blast but they're not top tier
they're not second tier right you do
this yourself as well maybe you're not
thinking about it
let's go talk about students okay
talk about students what different types
of students are there in business lowest
level is what those that are just there
but not paying attention to nothing
that's going on okay
number two level of students what
somebody that's there and maybe paying
attention number three is what somebody
that's there paying attention and maybe
actually reading the homework and
assignment that's given what's number
four somebody that's there paying
attention reading the assignment raising
question hypothetically what's next
somebody that does all of that stuff
asks the question rebuttal involves goes
a little bit deeper and then you keep
going to the levels right then i think
at the top level one of the top three
levels in my eyes
is the student
that
knows more than anybody else in the room
but acts like they don't know anything
so and what do i mean by this
epictitis i think is his name this
philosopher stoic philosopher
said
it's impossible for a man to learn
anything that he already thinks he knows
let me say this one more time it's
impossible for man to learn anything
that he already thinks he knows i'll say
it one more time it's impossible for a
man to learn anything that he thinks he
already knows which means what you're
sitting there and the attitude is kind
of like yeah i already know this stuff
no you don't though
yeah but i do i know this stuff no you
don't it's a blind spot
you're no longer a good student you used
to be a good student you were hungry you
wanted to learn you were yearning for
information
but now just because you've read 78
books and you can quote something from
some startup book or blue ocean book or
whatever
you're so cool and you already know
everything and you're done you know how
scary of a blind spot it is
because like this
everything can disappear you know why
because in life nobody in businesses
grow like this
and stay you can never in business stay
like this
if you ever get to a point where you get
too cocky and you're no longer learning
your business either grows or it drops
never stays pla never plateaus and stays
flat like that it never does that so for
you if you're watching this saying pat
what are you talking about in my office
i'm king kong when i walk in everybody
stops when i go to conventions everybody
stops when i walk into that event when i
go on social and i talk in different
environments everybody knows i'm a major
influence all this other stuff yeah but
at every level there's levels to this
game which level are you are you level
tier seven and there's no way you're
going to be tier 9 or 10 or 12 because
you already know it all and you have to
make that shift because if you don't
there's so much you don't know about to
get to the next level but you got to be
willing to stay humble and stay a great
student today even though you're killing
it to make it to the next level
and if you don't you're gonna revert
back to the last level you used to be a
year ago two years ago three years ago
not because i'm telling you it's going
to happen because history keeps making
this happen to people over and over and
over again in life and business and
sports in every single industry what i
share with you happens every single day
so having said that
if you got value from this video your
top performer give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel if you know
others who are top performers share this
video with them but i got another video
to share with you
with this right here and it's two videos
and you never get this enough times to
watch both of these videos that i'm
gonna re-recommend because watching it
one time is not enough to understand
this concept
you have to be curious about reaching
your capacity and i got two videos for
you one of them if you've watched the
kobe bryant interview but it's been a
year six months 18 months go watch it
again because you'll understand his
level of obsession about winning even if
you just let it play in the background
and you internalize the content the
other video that i put up once before
that if maybe you watch it two years ago
year and a half ago but you haven't seen
it for a while go watch it again that
title is how to reach your full
potential pick one of these two videos
go watch them and with that being said
have a great week everybody take care
bye
[Music]
you